entramos en el edificio de la
administración regional de hatcliffe
acompañados del ejército hoy con la
contraofensiva militar ucraniana ante la
invasión rusa en este frente la
seguridad se ha intensificado la
destrucción de este edificio regional de
la administración de jarquín muestra
como esta guerra está destrozando por
completo esta ciudad es complicado
caminar por aquí hay restos de ventanas
cristales también chaquetas de personas
que en ese momento del ataque estaban
aquí la cifra oficial de fallecidos son
50 personas pero no sólo atacaron el
edificio regional también el resto de la
plaza que quedó destruida y ahora mismo
están intentando arreglarla donde se
muestra más el nivel y el alcance de
este ataque es al fondo de este pasillo
ese gran agujero un misil impacto y casi
parto por la mitad este edificio
regional la artillería rusa está a unos
40 kilómetros así que es poco probable
que fuera un ataque con artillería y lo
que se sospecha es que fueron en misiles
de medio o largo alcance de los que
impactaron
contra este edificio regional de jarquín
minutos después se llega a la alerta
[Aplausos]
cáritas
bien dicho de irnos rápidamente de esta
esta zona porque podría haber ataques en
cuenta el momento
hoy la artillería retumba en esta ciudad
prácticamente desierta la alerta es
máxima